all right Mohawk Matt
Mohawk where do you grow up where are
you from originally uh San Fernando
Valley I'd say like the east side of the
San Fernando Valley
tell me about your uh your family
growing up you had uh both your parents
I was adopted I came from a pretty good
uh I guess I'd say Lord a middle class
family working in the San Fernando
Valley lived in Mission Hills and moved
to Sun Valley
how far did you go to school
I was pretty good I went to private
elementary school I was altar boy did
the whole nine yards of doing Catholic
Elementary and transitioned into a
public school system in the junior high
area
you know Charlotte was good
childhood was pretty good yeah it was
good yeah
tell me about your youth you were into
what kind of stuff I was into sports I
played a lot of baseball soccer I was
supposed to have played professional
baseball but later on you'll hear I
chose a night of drugs over uh losing
some Scholarships in baseball but I
found graffiti at a really young age
graffiti in the San Fernando Valley in
the early 90s and late 80s was humongous
and I got fully involved in it as a kid
and that eventually LED you to gangs
eventually throughout the 90s the
progression in the Streets of L.A where
most of the Italian Crews joined gangs I
unfortunately fell into that myself yeah
you got a couple tattoos too oh I've got
I'm completely covered in tattoos I've
removed them to put new ones on removed
them again yeah
well you've done some prison time I've
done it significant about 19 years in
prison wow yeah
so you're you're you had a
future as a as an athlete yes what
happened but
as my growing up I grew up
as the graffiti moved industry gangs I
uh one of my best best her friends back
when I was younger at Chubbs convinced
me one night after not trying any drugs
at all I'm talking I didn't smoke
marijuana never had a beer excuse me
never tried even a cigarette I tried to
crack cocaine one night out of the blue
at 21 years of age it was an immediate
within one year's time I lost every
single freaking thing I owned I lost my
scholarships I lost every chance my my
college was blown crack cocaine just
took me for a whirlwind I learned that
last
it lasted a few years and I had in order
to get off of crack cocaine I made the
wise choice of injecting crystal meth
and that that's a whole other ball game
yeah Kristoff can do that but I was able
unfortunately I don't know what's going
on around here but
I was able to do real crystal meth and
real amphetamine uh speed nowadays
there's so much stuff in these drugs
that you don't know what you're getting
from one hour to the next so you're not
Mexican you're not black you're you're
no I'm a white boy I grew up with
Mexicans that's part of my story and I
always make sure it's known I'm one of
those white boys one of four in a
neighborhood of all Mexicans that grew
up with them and I love them just like
myself what kind of gangs were you in I
was from a street gang that was
predominantly Mexican it wasn't
technically Mexican at the time I mean
it wasn't technically like I guess you'd
say South side at the time but evolved
into that over the years yeah
and then in prison
when I went to prison I made the
extremely
smart choice for myself but unwise on a
gang aspect choice to stay with my own
race and that caused a lot of turmoil in
my neighborhood at home as they
progressed into the more
south side angle of a gang and I stayed
with my race
um so the gang story in prison is very
different than on the streets a lot of
people don't understand that but just
because you're from a street gang
doesn't always necessarily mean you're
going to be involved in that click in
prison
I'm white and I didn't know my ass from
a hole in the wall when I went to the
county jail in the 90s I remember one
white guy asking me one question that
sticks with me to this day he said what
race are you and I said I'm white well
that's where my journey began I went
that way I had no idea what was going on
when you go to the county jail and if
you know anything about the county jail
in the early 90s it was a very scary and
a very dangerous place to be
and you were in prison for what
uh numerous things my first time was I
think criminal threats and some uh
shoplifting uh assault assault battery
my last term was two counts of criminal
threats felony vandalism a kidnapping
and home invasion yeah
but you straightened out your life yeah
when I got out of prison I had to beat a
drug addiction pretty gnarly it took me
a while getting out of prison I paroled
in 2013
I want to say about about for about five
years I was lost I was strung out on
drugs in my mom's house destroyed my
mother's million dollar home and she
moved to from the valley to Santa
Clarita I mean I destroyed I gutted a
million dollar home
in the process of trying to trying to
get myself back to normal because I came
home from prison unlike the military
with way more PTSD than I ever did in
the military
what kind of stuff did you see in prison
I am one of those dudes that doesn't
like to talk too much about prison I
I'll tell I tell some stories a couple
things that I've gone through um one of
the worst things I can honestly say that
I don't think I've admitted this on
camera but I saw a kid's head get cut
off I saw two inmates due to a racial
situation attacked this one kid
repeatedly over and over until his head
fell off
and it was right in front of me and in
prison if you know when they hit those
alarms you're you have to lay down on
the ground and I'm prone down on the
ground in the yard 20 feet from me these
two skinheads are attacking this other
inmate because he chose the wrong racial
affiliation and I can still When I close
my eyes see the you can see it like this
is stuff you can never unsee I don't
care who you are what you've been
through when you go to some of these
places in prisons it's extremely scary
if you're the toughest of the tough I
tell you you're full of [ __ ] because
these places make every grown gangster
scared and I remember these two inmates
just stabbing this kid so many times his
head finally fell off and they kicked
his head and when when someone dies
especially when there's that much blood
loss there's so much blood that these
kids were slipping in the blood they
were covered in blood The Blood starts
to coagulate and get hard mind you the
cops have not responded because they're
horrified at what they saw also cops are
known for getting stuck Frozen in fear
too that this one this scene went on for
about 20 minutes until finally the kids
stopped threw the knives down and they
sat there and they said come on I'll
never forget to look I can close my eyes
and see it the one kid sat there and
said come get me I'm done
mind you had already kicked this kid's
head rolling down the pathway of the
dirt and he's covered in blood and he
sits down and he had the audacity of you
to sit there and look at the cop and say
come arrest me I'm done and then to know
that I just watched cops watch you do
this and not react on it also was
amazing the tower lady was a female
officer in the tower she had the M1 and
she didn't shoot because she's Frozen
with fear also people don't understand
that these acts when you see them with
the human eyes they're they're startling
they freeze you and and I was me me
laying down was scared too and mind you
this is a situation that now took 24
hours of our day because excuse me this
situation now turns into a crime scene
local police out in the Calipatria area
of uh Imperial up by uh San Bernardino
past there they bring cops in this is
now a crime scene you can't move you're
stuck on the yard where they're bringing
you water in a sandwich because you
can't move either it turns into a crime
scene it was just that's one of probably
about five stories I have like that that
just sometimes I can't unsee at night so
I have to deal with it is yeah have you
ever living on the streets
to me I have to be honest with you to me
living on the streets was me and my my
SUV Lincoln parked in my mom's driveway
she kicked me out and I but kicked out
to me was living in the driveway in a
Lincoln SUV you know I had to beg to
shower my drug use took me to some
release I would say my drug use took me
to worse places for my family than on
the streets like like some other people
what do you make of that whole lifestyle
gangs and drugs and all that I think
they're intertwined yet at the same time
they're not they're intertwined but
they're not I say that strongly because
I remember being from a gang if I'd get
anything smoking crack was horrified you
had to hide in shame if you injected
meth heroin fentanyl you had to hide in
shame it wasn't something the homies
were okay with let alone the behavior
you see outside here and everywhere else
around you building in America this open
drug use that you see like in the day my
people would have you probably would
have got beat up for that you can't do
that in front of women and children uh
uh just regular women going to work
that's just not tolerated and I I feel
that it's it's gotten to a scary place
the scary place
how'd you finally get clean
May 18 2018 I finally got clean how'd
you do it well uh this is the best part
of my story I've repeated
um for about two weeks I was laying in
my mom's house in the spare room in the
dark watching pornography uh trying to
pretend that I look sexy and I weigh 80
pounds sweaty mind you I've been going
I've started to go bald so I'm growing
my hair and I look like I look like a
monster my hair's not shaven I'm not
shaving I'm sweaty I'm wearing a wife
beater that's four sizes too big it's
size extra large and it's hanging off me
um I've been doing meth and heroin back
and forth I remember the last day like
it was yesterday I mean I did 17 shots
of meth and heroin all over my body the
last injection I think I did I just told
this was in the vein in my penis and I
shot this dope in my meat in my penis
and it didn't work nothing's working and
I and I had been begging God I believe
in Jesus I also believe in Odin because
I am Viking in culture I've been praying
to both of them God uh remove this take
this from me please take this away from
me I can't handle it I'm ready to stop
but I don't know how I have been praying
excuse me night after night for this to
stop and this last day it wasn't working
and I finally after about 17 shots of
meth or heroin that weren't getting me
high and I'm not missing the vein either
I remember just putting the needle down
doing oh my God my prayers have been
answered they've been answered I'm not
smart enough to deal with it and I
remember I knocked on my door and I
opened the door and I called my mom's
name I said Mom I'm ready please get me
out of here what do I got to do
what I got to do
I tell people this you can't get sober
for your neighbor for your mom you can't
even do it for your kids you have to be
at a place where you are spiritually and
mentally broke when you are at that
bottom looking up that's that's probably
the only time you're going to realize
it's time to change and I was willing to
do anything if you told me to mop your
toilet out 17 times a day give me the
mop whatever you said for me to do Mark
whatever you needed me to do at that
moment I would have done it just to stay
off those drugs and away from them
because I was done it's the hardest
thing you've ever done
I've been to prison a level four and
I've been in the U.S Navy as a fireman I
have been in street gangs I've been shot
at shot stabbed jumped yes that was
definitely the hardest thing I'd rather
fight six Crips again before I before I
had to uh get sober is the heroin that
was the hardest part no funny enough I
tell people this a lot I got off of
heroin extremely easier than I got off
of that myth meth kicked my ass I had
the same symptoms coming off that method
as people out here do on heroin
no really help
what do you what do you think of the
whole culture now of what's going on in
La I know the gangs the homeless the
whole thing gangs I've noticed are
starting to read full circle they're
starting to come back I'm watching the
news a lot and I notice gangs are coming
back which is scary because in the 90s
when I grow up gangs were way different
way more active way more violent and it
looks like it's going back to that
the drug culture I mean I'm an addict
myself and I say this as lightly as I
can I'm not okay with them being allowed
to do drugs everywhere on the streets
you're setting the wrong message the
cops I'm not against the cops I'm also
not for them I try to stay out of their
way so they can do their job
um but a few weeks ago I was watching I
was down here watching as they they pull
up and watched a naked woman inject
heroin and then drove off when she was
done and I'm like
I just I'm scared for La I'm from L.A
I'm from the valley but we're still L.A
and I'm just scared to watch what's
evolving around us there's no
consequences
for it and it seems like it's getting
worse and it's getting worse can't take
my girlfriend or kids to walk in some
parks because they've taken over the
parks
and I feel that there's a definite
difference in like mental health you
talked about this on your show there's a
difference in homelessness mental health
and drug addiction
and a lot of the times I feel that we're
missing out and helping some people
realizing that you're just helping
someone get high and they don't need
help getting high
I walk people all the time if anybody
asks me for food okay let's go liquor
store I'll get you some chips or get you
a soda I'm not giving you money I'm not
buying you cigarettes or alcohol either
if you're hungry cool but I'm not going
to hand anybody cash I think nine times
out of ten nine times out of ten you you
know what they'll say I'm cool then
thanks no but nine times out of ten when
you're giving an addict money here well
nine times out of ten you give an addict
money it is not going to food it is
going through drugs cigarettes or
alcohol yeah
your life is better now my life's
amazing now I work for a great I work
for the biggest tattoo clothing company
in the world I I've been traveling the
world going to conventions with this
company I model I would never thought my
junky ass would be modeling you know I
mean especially at my age too
yeah
you have kids or your girlfriend I have
a son who's 23 he doesn't talk to me
much I uh
I have to deal with the fact that when I
went to prison I uh I had every his
mother gave me every chance and I didn't
pay attention to it and uh I went to
prison and signed away my rights I
thought it was the best choice because
my plan on going to prison was to get as
actively involved in the politics and
the gangs as I could and to not come
home and make a name for myself
but when I finally came home I realized
that was a mistake and I'm my son talks
to me here and there he kind of just
messages me because he wants free
clothing
but he doesn't want to have a
relationship with me really and I have
to respect it
what's your biggest fear
my biggest fear
sometimes I feel like with my son my
biggest fear is like I don't get to tell
you I just wanted him to hear why
I did what I did I want my son to know
that like I didn't walk away from you I
just I made the best decision for you I
thought at the time I was involved in
gangs and drugs and the reason I walked
away from you is because I didn't think
I was coming home and I thought he
deserved a better shot at a life without
me in hindsight you realize well I
changed my life damn he had a better
shot with me and now I might have lost
that shot
other than that my biggest fear is
probably losing my mom she's my best
friend total best friend sorry about
that yeah what advice do you give to
young men that are thinking of joining a
gang or women
don't if I could go back to when my
Titan crew joined I remember I remember
this night when we had a meeting we had
a meeting and I I was probably one of
three of us that didn't want to do it
and we just did it out of some sense of
not wanting to be looked down on we
didn't want to be looked at it as weak
but I if I could do it again I would I
would do it again no disrespect to my
homeboys because I still love my
homeboys in my neighborhood in Sun
Valley but that choice
whether it be racially or whether it be
just and a broader Choice it was bad
I was into graffiti and artwork and
stuff like that I wasn't really the gang
thing wasn't me I adapted to it well but
yet at the same time it's not really me
I was more into art and music and I mean
I was a Gothic picture this a Gothic
punk rock cholo who plays first base
baseball
listen in a Gothic punk rock music
Depeche Mode I'm riding around on a
skateboard graffiti and trying to
gangbang it was a cluster [ __ ] but I did
it
your dad was not in your life my dad is
in my life that's the thing I let him
down too my dad's uh retired Air Force
uh vet Vietnam he just looks at me like
I've done my best to make amends but the
amends are still not good enough for him
the tattoos have gotta oh my God he
won't even go somewhere I was telling my
girlfriend this yesterday he won't even
go to the movies with me unless I'm
wearing a hoodie and a hat on top of the
hoodie or under the hoodie he will not
go out with me in public especially
because I have the [ __ ] the sheriff's
department tattoo right here for a I got
into a fist fight with a couple of them
off duty in Santa Clarita so I put this
on the side of my head to commemorate
that and that alone he won't even be
seen in public with me you have a tattoo
that says what [ __ ] the Sheriff's
Department
I got into a fist fight with a couple of
them off duty because they they thought
they could pick up on my girlfriend
because they're sheriffs they actually
told me this well we're sheriffs we can
do we want I said okay well that's my
girlfriend we ended up in the in the
parking lot in a fist fight
and I I mean I got with one of them but
but they they kind of got me after that
do you regret the tattoos
you know some of them I do I've removed
a lot of them I removed a lot of stupid
hateful gang tattoos that I had all over
me and I've since replaced them with
cool stuff I regret some of the some of
them that I've got yes definitely
the memories I made with them I don't
because there's stuff I've had to go
through and grow through
but some of them that I was dumb enough
to put on my body yeah I definitely
regret them I definitely do those are
the things you did in prison gangs
hateful nonsense all that gang stuff is
it's part of my history but it's not
where I'm at now and where I'm at now
wants to scream at that kid that I was
to tell them don't don't [ __ ] do that
don't wait on that tattoo for a month
just sit on it for a month you know
but I wish I could talk to my younger
self if you had your life to live all
over again what would you have done
different oh this is a bad question
because they just told this to my
homeboy lonely who did 29 years he got
out and someone asked him this
I want to say that I would do so much
different but at the same time if I did
that then I wouldn't be who I am right
now it's true if I didn't go through all
of that I couldn't be helping as many
people right now I'm sponsoring guys in
recovery from here to New to Great
Britain I've got guys using Instagram
and social media is amazing for me to
help people in recovery but if I wasn't
or didn't go through that I couldn't do
what I'm doing now I would have no if I
just got the job and sold cars or went
to school to be a lawyer I probably
would have been a great lawyer but I
wouldn't be able to touch as many people
I believe as I touch now
no what's your biggest regret
not finishing College not not staying in
my my son's life I think
but I have a second chance I got to go
for one with two kids that are amazing
little kids and right now I'm getting a
second chance by proxy to to relive that
are you happier now than you've ever
been I could say yeah I'm happy now I've
never been yeah yeah yeah where I'm at
with my girlfriend with my parents with
my mother with my company totally I'm
totally happy happier now than I've ever
been yeah how old are you I'm 45. I'm
about to be 46 in April
Matt what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
most important lesson I would say follow
your heart
your brain your dick might necessarily
lead you wrong but your heart usually
will lead you down the right way and
even if you make a mistake following
your heart it's something you can
probably easily fix
but if you listen to your brain
sometimes I think or your dick you're
probably going to make a bad decision
yeah that's great all right Matt thank
you so much for sharing your story thank
you for having me it was a pleasure good
luck with everything thank you